Volkswagen presents the new Golf R
variant for the first time with an
extended rear it packs 221 kilowatts of
power and up to 380 Newton meters of
torque the standard six-speed
dual-clutch gearbox progressive steering
and sports suspension lowered by 2
centimetres make it a real
high-performance little wagon the go far
variant may look tame at first sight but
it's a powerhouse the 4 gleaming
tailpipes already hint at that as do the
big breaks that bring the R variant to a
quick stop those 221 kilowatts can
produce between five thousand five
hundred and six thousand two hundred rpm
if you choose your shift point precisely
you'll be rewarded with a loud rumble
from the exhaust system the our wagon
rockets to 100 kilometers an hour in 5.1
seconds and has a top speed of 250
kilometers an hour without the speed
limitation device it can reach 270
former race driver Klaus needs Fitz is
testing the our variant for us on the
secreto Ascari in Spain where he can
really put the meaty station wagon
through its paces the sport setting
allows the electronic stability program
to perform gentle harmonious trips the
standard all-wheel drive also helps
transmit all the power of the
supercharged 2-liter four-cylinder
engine to the road Klaus says power
isn't restricted to the cars sound here
you have 300 horsepower and plenty of
torque 380 Newton meters are quite an
advantage when you come out of a turn
with low revs then when you step on the
gas the car shoots ahead
he's not falling on the ESC sports
setting can be deactivated for laps on a
race track one of the emotional
highlights is the newest generation of
the DCC adaptive chassis control whose
choice of driving profiles includes a
race mode
it's altogether
Klaus is thrilled the our variant
reaches 260 kilometers an hour here in
the straightaway
and he says 270 is possible on the
Autobahn when you hit the brakes at that
speed you feel the seatbelt more than
you'd like but a powerful brake system
is just what a car this sporty needs in
the interior the Gulf flagship boasts a
three-spoke leather sports steering
wheel automatic climate control and a
large touchscreen the r variant always
comes with a direct shift gearbox and
for motion permanent four-wheel drive
only high-quality materials go into the
go far and in our logo graces the sport
seats Klaus can hardly believe this is a
small van it definitely feels like a
sports car here on the Ascari race
course then he tests the car at a lower
speed after all it has families in mind
the kids in the back and mom and dad in
the front on shopping trips the car and
its engine are both well suited for
everyday use - on the attack stylish
coyote this autozone office motors is
shown by
so that's Vasya on the Ascari racetrack
our car tester is very impressed the car
has lots of power a top-notch
transmission good brakes and precise
steering the new VW Golf R variant
offers driving fun room and safety with
a whopping 221 kilowatt engine and a
1620 liters of storage space and leaves
little to be desired
in Germany the are very it starts at
forty two thousand nine hundred
twenty-five euros